the chairs gang is reuniting they're
back together all the Goldbergs Kirstie
Alley won an Emmy on that show but she's
still terrified about doing this I was
freaking out last night really horrible
when you're on somebody else's show and
you screw up and you see the people
their background like I'm gonna mention
now and I remember life
I could never remember my lines my lines
were written if you saw the cheers bar
my I used to carry a a cigar box with me
my lines were always in my cigar box
Jews ran for 11 seasons before ending in
1993 after 275 episodes and 28 Emmy went
now Kirstie dropping set secrets from
the show everybody knows your name we
never paid attention
we were always in trouble we never
showed up on time we didn't want to work
because Louie
we didn't want to work though you know
we had to move if me too had been around
when we did Cheers we would all be in
prison there's no way really no way I'm
not even kidding we used to take new
tees of each other we we kick open the
bathroom doors and take we were horrible
you can't even imagine this stuff we did
before we shoot we'd stick each other's
times down each other's throats I mean
nobody was saying no don't do it but I'm
just saying
same thing but now on the set of the
Goldbergs things are very different it
took a while to get Kirsty real Pearlman
John Ratzenberger and George went back
together for the special throwback
episode everybody's so nice and sweet
and like so reverent and everything is
there anything from the eighties day
don't try to make out with me sir hello
ma'am I just wanted to confirm that your
order was up to our standards sure but
my standards are very low should they
bring back tears should you get one more
crack it does involve doesn't make any
sense not to cuz we're old people and
old people sit at bars
[Music]
[Applause]